[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Today
I want to discuss
nucleic acid metabolism.
But before getting
to that, I want
to take a step
back and talk a bit
about what we closed with last
time, which was discussing
serine, glycine
metabolism and how
they can be used to generate
one-carbon units that
are for one-carbon
transfer reactions.
And these are one-carbon
transfer reactions
moving carbon that's
more reduced than CO2.
You'll remember, if we're going
to do a carboxylation reaction,
transfer of CO2, that
often uses biotin,
whereas if you're transferring
a one-carbon unit that's
more reduced than CO2, it comes
from these folate species.
And we described some of the
different folate species--
N5-methyl-THF, which can
donate a fully reduced
one-carbon unit, a
methyl group, to SAM,
SAM being the
universal methyl donor
for most methylation
reactions in cells.
You can also have folates carry
more oxidized one-carbon units,
N5, N10-methylene-THF
and N10-formyl-THF.
And those will be
very important today
as we discuss one-carbon
transfer reactions
and nucleotide synthesis.
Now, I recognize that
folate metabolism
can be very confusing.
The structures are complex.
The names are long and
convoluted and hard
to incorporate.
But if you can think of
it as just transferring
one-carbon units of a
different oxidation state,
hopefully that will help
you better understand what's
going on in folate reactions.
And so really, all it
is, remember, serine
has three carbons.
Glycine has two carbons.
And so when you convert
serine to glycine,
you end up generating
a one-carbon unit.
As I showed you in
the lecture last time,
this one-carbon unit is in the
formaldehyde oxidation state.
And so ultimately,
that's generated.
That's donated to
a folate species
to generate this carrier,
the N5, N10-methylene-THF,
which you can really think of as
a carrier for one-carbon units
in the formaldehyde
oxidation state.
Now, those can undergo
an oxidation reaction.
And so if we oxidize that carbon
from the aldehyde to the acid,
now we end up getting
the N10-formyl-THF.
All right, so that's
carrying the one-carbon unit
as the acid.
Or we can reduce that one-carbon
unit to the methyl group.
And that's carrying it
as the N5-methyl-THF,
so carrying this as a methyl
group, more reduced carbon
than where we started.
And so try to cut through
all the names and whatnot
and just realize that it's
simply transfers of carbon
in different oxidation states.
And the relevant
ones today is going
to be N10-formyl and N5,
N10-methylene-THF because it
turns out generating
those oxidized
one-carbon units, formate
groups, et cetera,
is going to be important
for purine as well
as thymine synthesis.
OK, so our topic today
is really to discuss
how we generate
nucleic acids, how
we break down purines and
pyrimidines or purines.
And this is really the final
topic here in the course.
In some ways, it's a bit fitting
because it really incorporates
lots of aspects of metabolism
that we've been discussing
over the course of the
semester, all come together
in nucleotide metabolism.
Now, nucleotide metabolism
itself is a very large topic,
probably deserves more
than one 90 minute lecture.
But unfortunately, the
time is what it is.
And we just don't have time
to cover every single detail.
However, we can go
pretty fast and at least
give you a flavor
of what's going on
because as I've alluded to, this
draws to lots of metabolism.
I drew here just a
very skeletonized view
of glycolysis, the TCA cycle,
the pentose phosphate pathway,
couple aspects of amino acid
synthesis, folate metabolism,
and drew boxes around
all the precursors
that are necessary to
generate various nucleotides.
And you can see
it's really drawn
from across these
metabolic pathways.
As we go through
these, you'll see
that you actually know a lot.
And this synthesizes,
really, what
we've learned from lots of
other pathways coming together
into understanding how cells
make purines and pyrimidines.
Now down here, I've color
coded all the different--
so here's a pyrimidine.
Here's a purine,
the ring structure
that you're probably familiar
with from these purines
and pyrimidines--
and color coded where
it is that each of these
atoms come from, where they're
drawn from across metabolism.
And again, it's a
nice way to sort
of synthesize lots
of the pathways
that we've discussed in class.
Now ribose also is going to
come from ribose 5-phosphate.
That's, of course, a product of
the pentose phosphate pathway,
oxidative or non-oxidative,
depending on how the cell wants
to use those pathways--
the Calvin cycle
and photosynthesis,
lots of ways to get
ribose 5-phosphate.
That generates the ribose.
And then there's a
lot of complexity
that goes into how one builds
these complex base structures.
Now, we just want to start here
and show you on the slide here,
here's a general purine base.
Here's a general
pyrimidine base.
Kind of a stupid mnemonic
that's always helped me
that maybe will help you if
you need to remember which
of these is the purine and
which of these is the pyrimidine
as you go through, take MCAT
exams or something like that--
so the purine ring looks
kind of like a pope hat.
And the pope is pure.
And so it's kind
of stupid, but it's
one way to remember that this
pope hat-looking structure is
the purine.
And the other one
is the pyrimidine.
Of course, you're familiar
with purines and pyrimidines
because these generate
the various bases that
are used for RNA and DNA, so
adenine and guanine, the two
purine bases in RNA
and DNA, and then
cytosine and uracil in RNA,
and cytosine and thymine
in DNA are the pyrimidine
bases in RNA and DNA.
Now, these are, of course,
not the only possible purines
and pyrimidines.
They're not the only
purines and pyrimidines
that nature cares about.
Here's a few other
ones shown here.
And so here is uric acid.
Uric acid, as we've
discussed, is the way birds
excrete nitrogen. We'll
discuss later today
that it's the cause of gout,
a very common human condition.
There's also lots of other
pharmacologically active
molecules among the
purines and pyrimidines.
So here's caffeine, certainly
a very important molecule
for many of us to get
going in the morning.
There's things like adenine.
So adenine plus the ribose sugar
is a molecule called adenosine.
Adenosine is a very
important signaling molecule
in our bodies.
If you go to medical
school, you'll
use adenosine to figure
out people's heart rhythms.
There's also lots
of drugs that come
from purines and pyrimidines.
So here's an example here.
This is the drug 5-fluorouracil,
a widely used cancer drug.
And so it's an analog
of a pyrimidine.
Lots of anti-cancer drugs
as well as antimicrobials
end up being drugs
that interfere
with nucleotide metabolism
and often are analogs
of purines and pyrimidines.
Now the first general
comment I want to make
is that in cells, the
free bases of these things
are much less useful
than the nucleosides
and the nucleotides.
And so just to remind you of
a little bit of nomenclature
is that these purine and
pyrimidine bases are usually
attached to ribose
and a nucleoside.
So a nucleoside is basically
the base, purine and pyrimidine
base, plus ribose,
but no phosphate.
All right, so adenosine
would be adenine stuck
to ribose, but no
phosphates on it.
That's adenosine.
And then you have
your nucleotides.
And the nucleotides are the base
plus the ribose plus phosphate.
And so it can be nucleotide
monophosphate, diphosphate,
triphosphate, AMP, ADP, ATP--
examples of nucleotides.
Now, there are two major ways
that cells build nucleotides.
And that is they can
make them de novo.
So de novo is building
them from scratch.
Or you'll see that they can
so-called salvage the bases.
And this is, you might
imagine, that if as animals, we
eat other organisms.
We take in their RNA and DNA.
We get some of these
purine and pyrimidine bases
that these can be salvaged--
that is, added back
to ribose to generate
nucleosides and nucleotides.
And you'll see, as we go through
how you do de novo synthesis,
that making these
things is complex.
It's energetically expensive.
And so, of course,
salvaging prevents
you having to expend this
energy and effort in order
to generate them de novo.
I also want to remind
you because it's
evident in the fact that
uric acid is a way that birds
and reptiles can excrete
nitrogen is that just back
to our prior discussion, that
in the world, in the biosphere,
nitrogen is a
precious commodity.
Remember, it has to be fixed.
It's not infinitely available.
Relatively few organisms can fix
nitrogen into its useable form.
And so salvaging premade
bases is salvaging
nitrogen in a usable form.
And so evolutionarily,
for a lot of organisms,
that's also a
beneficial thing to do.
All right, now another last
sort of introductory comment
about why this lecture ends
up being important and having
some appreciation
of these pathways
is that certainly if you
go to medical school,
you will come across
all kinds of things
having to do with the
metabolism of today's lecture.
And that's because it turns
out that making nucleosides
and making nucleotides
is limiting
for proliferation in all
kinds of biological contexts.
And this is really back to
what I alluded to earlier.
A lot of our anti-cancer
drugs, they also
end up being anti-inflammatory.
So things to treat inflammatory
diseases and cancer oftentimes
are things that block steps
in nucleotide metabolism.
Lots of antimicrobials
or antibiotics
also attack some of
the same pathways,
but are more specific
for bacterial rather than
human enzymes.
And so really, these
drugs converge on pathways
that either produce or
salvage nucleotides.
And it's good to have
some appreciation of where
these things are acting
because this ends up
being really important
for all kinds of aspects
of human medicine, as
well as understanding
other bits of biology.
All right, now either
de novo synthesis
of purine and
pyrimidine nucleotides
or salvage of those things,
of purine and pyrimidine
nucleotides, needs to add
the base somehow to a ribose.
And that starts with generating
a molecule called PRPP,
also abbreviated up there
in my general overview.
This stands for polyribo--
sorry, stands for phosphoribose
pyrophosphate, PRPP,
phosphoribose pyrophosphate.
So what is that?
Well, this is, if we draw here
our ribose sugar and we draw it
in the alpha-furanose
form, so this would be
alpha-5-ribose-phosphate so--
sorry, alpha-ribose 5-phosphate.
OK, so that's
ribose 5-phosphate.
That's generated from pentose
phosphate pathway, generated
from the Calvin cycle, whatever.
This is really
starting point, discuss
lots of ways we
can generate that
through different pathways.
Well, if we take ATP
and convert it to AMP--
that is, transfer
two phosphates,
pyrophosphorylate
the one position--
now we end up with
this molecule.
OK, so this molecule
here would be PRPP,
so phosphoribose pyrophosphate.
And PRPP can pick up a
nitrogen, either the nitrogen
from the base if it's
the salvage pathway
or whatever
nitrogen-containing molecule
is going to be the first step
in de novo synthesis, which
we'll get to later,
and basically releases
the pyrophosphate.
That can be cleaved to
two inorganic phosphates,
pull the reaction forward.
And what one ends up with
is basically this nitrogen
added either as the nucleoside
monophosphate or some precursor
to nitrogen-containing precursor
to the nucleoside monophosphate
that we can then build the
purine or pyrimidine base
on top.
And so the dogma is that de
novo synthesis of nucleotides
is important for new
proliferation of cells
or a salvage is important
for maintenance of cells.
This is a huge
oversimplification.
It's effectively untrue
as far as I'm concerned.
Lots of drugs that
affect salvage
can affect diseases involved
in proliferation and whatnot.
But nonetheless, you should
just realize that these early
steps-- that is, adding PRPP--
is important either
to salvage things
or to do de novo synthesis.
Now today, given our
limited amount of time,
I'm really going to focus on
de novo synthesis of purines
and pyrimidines.
I will discuss a little bit
about purine catabolism.
Mainly this is because these are
the most topics where there's
something to say about
biochemistry and metabolism
that builds off a
lot of the themes
that we've covered in the class.
They also focus on lots of
aspects of relevant medicine.
And so those of you who
go to medical school
will see this again.
And I want you to
appreciate it a little bit.
And particularly, some
aspects of salvage
are important in
biology and medicine.
But really, my goal
today is not for you
to understand absolutely every
chemical step that goes on,
but really to appreciate
how these things happen
and hopefully
synthesize some of what
you've learned over the
course of the semester.
All right, so let's talk first
about how you make purines,
purine synthesis.
So purine synthesis, you
should know your MIT history.
So the purine synthesis
pathway, the de novo--
that is building
purines from scratch--
was largely worked out by a guy
by the name of Jack Buchanan.
He partially did this at MIT.
He basically was recruited
from elsewhere, came to MIT.
And when he was at MIT,
also was the person
who really modernized the
MIT biology department
to be what it is today.
So prior to Jack Buchanan,
biology department
was much more about ecology
and things like that.
And really, he moved the
MIT biology department
into the molecular era.
And so for the MIT
students, it's good for you
to appreciate some
of our history.
All right, now
purine synthesis--
as I said, I'm going
to go through all
the steps of purine synthesis.
You'll see it's
complicated, all right?
I will show you some
of the chemistry.
I don't have time to
go into great detail
or explain all of the
steps in great detail.
But again, my goal
here is for you
to appreciate how
purines are made,
not necessarily memorize all
the steps in the pathway.
All right, so purine
synthesis starts
with phosphoribose
pyrophosphate, OK?
We're going to build
on the ribose base.
And the first step
is taking glutamine
and converting it to glutamate.
So what is that transferring?
That's transferring a nitrogen.
Remember, the difference
between glutamine and glutamate,
you can pick that up
with glutamine synthase,
is that was one way to put an
ammonia onto glutamate to make
glutamine.
And so this ends up
carrying out the reaction
that I showed you
earlier and adds
a nitrogen to the ribose sugar,
giving you this compound.
All right, the next step is
to take a glycine molecule.
And that glycine molecule
gets phosphorylated with ATP.
So phosphorylate the carboxylic
acid on the glycine molecule,
and then this will combine
with the prior molecule,
releasing phosphate and
generating this molecule, which
I'm now going to just draw
phosphoribose as like that
because drawing ribose over and
over again will become painful.
And that generates
this intermediate,
which is called
glycinamide ribonucleotide.
I'm not going to
write out nucleotide.
And you will see that many of
the steps in purine synthesis
end up having these
abbreviations.
This one is called GAR for
glycinamide ribonucleotide.
And you'll see, as we get
these long complex names,
why one uses these abbreviations
like GAR, which are actually
used quite commonly.
All right, the
next step is we're
going to add a one-carbon
unit, a formate group.
So remember, the formate carrier
comes from N10-formyl-THF.
And so-- eraser--
going to come from
N10-formyl-THF, all right?
So that's going to take
the one-carbon unit off
to regenerate THF, which,
of course, can pick up
the one-carbon unit again
from serine and glycine,
and then undergo an
oxidation reaction to get
the formate group,
the N10-formyl-THF.
And that generates
this intermediate,
which is called FGAR for formyl
GAR, so formylglycinamide
ribonucleotide, or FGAR.
All right, the next step is
we're going to add a nitro--
basically swap this oxygen here
on this carbonyl to a nitrogen,
so a C double bond
to a nitrogen bond.
And that requires--
so that's going
to come from glutamine again.
And it requires ATP.
And it's somewhat of
a complex reaction.
And I think it's--
again, I will show you very
briefly how this works.
If you don't follow all of
it, don't worry about it.
But basically, if we just
draw the middle part here
of the molecule, I don't want
to draw out the whole thing.
So basically, this is
phosphorylation here.
So the phosphate from
ATP transferred here
to give this intermediate.
That will lose a water,
giving this intermediate.
Then the ammonia from
glutamine to glutamate
come here, release
the phosphate.
And then typically, this
is drawn where we just
rearrange the double bond.
And one ends up with
this intermediate,
which is called FGAM.
So this is this
intermediate, which
is FGAM for formyl glycinamide
ribonucleotide, so FGAM.
All right, makes sense?
All right, the next reaction
is also a little bit complex
and maybe hard to see.
Again, I will draw it out.
If you don't follow all of
it, don't worry about it.
But it's nice for
those of you who
want to follow it to
see what's happening.
So again, now we're going
to take another ATP,
hydrolyze it to ADP plus
Pi, release of water.
And in the end, what
we're going to generate
is we're going to close this
ring to generate-- so we're
going to close
that ring, so make
a bond from this nitrogen to
this carbon, close this ring.
This generates this intermediate
called AIR, or amino ribo--
sorry, aminoimidazole
ribonucleotide.
Don't worry about
the long names.
Everyone would just call it AIR.
So how does this happen?
Well, it happens as follows.
So first step is
phosphorylation of--
so ATP will phosphorylate
the aldehyde
to give this intermediate.
Water's lost.
OK, now you have this
nitrogen down here, can--
losing the phosphate.
OK, so that will end
up closing the ring
on that side of the molecule.
And then all I've done is I've
just removed the electrons
here so that rather than being
a carbon-nitrogen double bond,
it's now a carbon-carbon
double bond.
And that generates FGAM
to AIR, costing an ATP--
again, one of the more
complicated reactions to see.
Again, if you're into
how the reactions work,
hopefully I gave you enough
information to understand it.
If you're not, just realize
that this is the next step.
OK, the next step is a reaction
that's very similar to one
that we saw in the urea cycle.
And that is we
are going to add--
oh, sorry.
The next step is one that--
sorry.
Before we do that
step, the next step
is one where we're going to
add a CO2 group to this carbon.
So that's a
carboxylation reaction.
You would typically think
of a carboxylation reaction
to involve biotin.
This is one that doesn't.
It's an exception to that
rule, does not involve biotin.
But it does involve ATP.
OK, so remember, the way
we did this before is we
would have phosphorylation
of our bicarbonate.
So use ATP to
phosphorylate bicarbonate.
And so if we just draw this
part of the molecule here,
displacing the phosphate, and
then what we end up with is--
OK, we end up with that.
And if I just rearrange so
that the double bond is here
instead of there, then we end
up with this next intermediate,
which is CAIR or carboxy-AIR,
so CAIR or carboxy-AIR.
All right, now we
get to the step
that's very similar to the one
that we saw in the urea cycle
where we're going to use
aspartate to fumerate
conversion to add a nitrogen
to this carboxylic acid.
And so you'll remember that way
we did that in the urea cycle
is we used ATP to AMP
conversion to end up
adding that aspartate group.
In this case, it's just
ATP to ADP plus Pi.
OK, so that's going to
phosphorylate this acid group.
OK, so I'm not going to
draw the whole thing.
Phosphorylate that,
and then we'll
have an aspartate molecule.
OK, so this is the
amino acid aspartate.
OK, and one gets--
didn't leave myself
enough room, but that's
an aspartate molecule bound up
there to that carboxylic acid,
just like we saw before.
This is a molecule
called SAICAR,
which is succinyl
amino imidazole
carboxy amide ribonucleotide.
OK, definitely everyone
calls it SAICAR.
Now just as we saw then
from the urea cycle,
we are now going to
take off a fumerate.
OK, so this is reaction
that you've seen before.
OK, just like we saw in the
urea cycle, so that reaction,
lose the fumerate.
And what you're left
with is basically
just the nitrogen left behind.
OK, and you get
this intermediate,
which is referred
to as AICAR, so
amino-imidazole-carboxy-amide
ribonucleotide,
so minus the succinate
group, AICAR.
OK, next step is we're
going to use a formate group
and add it to this nitrogen.
So that's straightforward.
So if we draw out
here our formate group
from N10-formyl-THF, so that
will be our N10-formyl-THF,
generate THF.
And then we get--
OK, let me get that
formate group added there.
And so this is FAICAR,
or formyl AICAR, FAICAR.
All right, next step is we're
going to close the ring.
And so close the ring,
that's going to give this.
OK, so that part of the
molecule where the ring closes,
it just rearrange like
that to lose water.
And that is going to generate
our purine ring the way
you're used to seeing it drawn.
And so this is the purine IMP
for inosine monophosphate.
And inosine monophosphate is
the precursor for all purines.
And so if you look at this,
what you see is that in the end,
there is two nitrogens that come
from ammonia, from glutamine
to glutamate, from the ammonia
released from glutamine
to glutamate, one nitrogen
here that comes from glycine,
and that nitrogen there
that comes from aspartate.
Two of the carbons, these two,
come from the formate group,
from N10-formyl-THF.
Another carbon up
here comes from CO2.
And the remaining
two carbons here
come from a glycine
molecule, with, of course,
the ribose phosphate from PRPP.
And so if you go
through, what you'll find
is that it took
two ATP to generate
the PRPP from ribose
phosphate-- so starting
with a ribose phosphate, two ATP
to generate the PRPP, and then
five additional ATPs.
So if you go up and look
through all the steps,
there are five steps that
require ATP, so quite
a lot of ATP to generate
this purine ring,
inosine monophosphate.
Now, inosine is not
found in RNA or DNA.
And so this has to
be, of course, turned
into adenine and guanine.
And so how does that happen?
Well, I'll show you.
And so turning it, inosine
monophosphate into adenine,
basically involves
putting a nitrogen here
instead of this
double bond to oxygen.
And so that occurs
via a very similar--
in fact, the same
reaction, that we
saw to take CAIR and
generate SAICAR, all right?
And so it was basically
using aspartate to transfer
that nitrogen. I
don't have time to go
through the whole mechanism.
But it's basically what
I already showed you.
And so you take GTP plus
acetate, get GDP plus Pi.
Note, you use
guanine triphosphate,
so GTP rather than ATP,
to end up generating
the adenine nucleotide.
All right, it's going
to release water.
Water was also released
in that reaction.
And what you end up with
is this intermediate.
So I'm not going to
draw the whole structure
for the sake of time.
But this here would be the
top here of the purine ring.
So this would have a--
so that's going to add an
aspartate molecule up there.
And then from that, we're
going to release fumerate.
OK, so fumerate comes off.
And what we're left with is--
OK, and this here is
adenosine monophosphate, AMP.
And, of course, I can just
take two phosphorylation events
and get ATP.
Basically, phospho
transfer ATP to make ADP,
and then, ultimately,
ADP to make
ATP via glycolysis, oxidative
phosphorylation, whatever.
And so that's how you
generate adenine nucleotides.
Generate guanine nucleotides,
what has to happen
is that we need to
put a nitrogen here.
OK, so putting a
nitrogen on this carbon,
first thing that
happens is we add water
across that double bond.
OK, so that's this part
here of the molecule,
added water across
that double bond.
Now we're going to oxidize
this carbon-nitrogen bond,
seen this a million times--
generates a hydride ion.
What's that hydride
ion-- or sorry,
oxidize this alcohol
to the ketone,
so generates a hydride ion.
Those electrons go to
NAD+, generate an NADH,
oxidation reaction.
And that gives us this.
OK, and then the next
step is that we're
going to take that ketone
that was generated here,
and we're going to turn
it into, basically,
replace that oxygen
with a nitrogen.
And so that's exactly the
reaction that we saw when
we went here from FGAR to FGAM.
All right, so if I
go from same reaction
that I used to go
from FGAR to FGAM,
so this is ATP goes
to ADP plus Pi.
All right, nitrogen
comes here from glutamine
to glutamate, same
reaction that occurs there.
Water comes off.
What I end up doing
is I replace this.
I'll end up getting
this structure instead.
And then I can just
rearrange the double bond
to be on the ring rather than to
the nitrogen outside the ring.
And that generates--
OK, and so this is GMP.
Notice that the ATP
was used to make GMP.
GTP was used to make AMP.
So use the opposite purine
to make each reaction.
I know I went through
these quickly,
just don't have time to
go into it in more detail.
But it's really just
repurposing similar reactions
that are involved
in purine synthesis
to end up changing this
inosine monophosphate
into AMP or into GMP.
And I guess for
consistency, I should
have drawn that in yellow
because the nitrogen comes
from the glutamine.
OK, so that is purine synthesis.
That's how you get AMP and GMP.
If you're going to
break these things down,
of course, you're going
to use separate pathways.
Why are you going to
use separate pathways?
Well, because as we've
heard over and over again
in the class, for
thermodynamic reasons,
delta G has to be less than
0 for any pathway to work,
can't be less than 0
in both directions.
One direction
needs energy input.
I had energy input to make
these purine nucleotides.
Opposite direction don't
need energy to make it.
I don't have time to
get into all the details
of purine breakdown.
Although, here are some things.
I just summarize it here
for you on this slide.
Basically, you start from AMP.
You take the phosphate off.
You end up generating adenosine.
You end up going to
inosine, remove the ribose.
Then you get another base.
And the base on
inosine monophosphate,
when it's just the base, so the
nucleoside and nucleotide is
inosine, when you get
rid of the ribose,
now the base is
called hypoxanthine.
It's a little bit of
a confusing thing.
But just recognize
that hypoxanthine
is the base that is found
on inosine or inosine
monophosphate, all right?
And so just to
summarize what I showed
you what was on the slide,
so to break down AMP,
you'd remove the phosphate.
Now you end up with the
nucleoside adenosine.
So that's adenine
plus the ribose.
Take off the nitrogen to move
back to the nucleoside inosine.
Now we can remove the
ribose from inosine.
What we're left with is the
base, which is hypoxanthine.
OK, so I'll draw out
hypoxanthine for you here.
OK, so hypoxanthine,
you'll see is basically
exactly what we drew out
for inosine monophosphate.
It's just the base from inosine
monophosphate is hypoxanthine.
Now if we oxidize this
carbon-nitrogen bond, which
is carried out by a
complex oxidation reaction,
requiring oxygen and water and
producing hydrogen peroxide
by an enzyme called
xanthine oxidase.
OK, so the enzyme xanthine
oxidase-- interesting enzyme--
has a molybdenum group.
And in it, is a cofactor
and iron and FAD--
a complex redox reaction we
don't have time to get into--
ends up generating
this purine base.
OK, this purine
base is xanthine.
Xanthine oxidase,
same enzyme, can also
use the same
chemistry to oxidize
this nitrogen-carbon bond.
So this one here, when
it was oxidized there,
now we're going to
oxidize this one here.
And what does that generate?
That generates this
compound, uric acid.
And so for the birds and
reptiles to excrete nitrogen,
it would synthesize
a purine like AMP,
and then break it
down to uric acid
as a way to eliminate
nitrogen, all right?
Guanine GMP, lose
a phosphate, you
get the nucleoside guanosine,
so guanine the base,
plus the ribose
with no phosphate.
Take the ribose group off.
Now we're left with guanine.
And then if we
start with guanine,
remove nitrogen from guanine,
then we end up with xanthine.
OK, so remember, there was
additional oxidation step
to make GMP that
wasn't there in AMP.
That means we get a more
oxidized product back
when we break it down.
So it's broken down to xanthine.
And that can be acted on
also to generate uric acid.
And so you could also
make GMP, and then
break down the GMP to
make uric acid as a way
to excrete nitrogen.
Now uric acid is also
medically important in humans.
This is, of course, the thing
that is the cause of gout.
So gout is uric acid, is
produced in excess, deposits
and crystallizes in joints
and causes a lot of pain.
And one way to treat gout
is with a xanthine oxidase
inhibitor.
There's a drug
called allopurinol
that inhibits xanthine oxidase.
And that ends up
being a way to slow
the production of uric acid and
can treat patients with gout.
All right, now, if
you break down purines
and you want to recapture
them, you can also use salvage.
And so to save some
time, here I drew out,
basically, the salvage
pathways for purines.
And so you can
start with adenine,
or you can start with guanine.
Or you can start
with hypoxanthine.
And basically, these are
simply added to PRPP.
So if you take adenine, add
it to PRPP, now you have AMP.
If you take hypoxanthine, add
it to PRPP, now you have IMP.
And you can use that IMP
to then synthesize AMP,
or not shown here, GMP, by the
pathways I've already shown.
Or if you have guanine, you
can salvage that guanine,
add it to PRPP, and
then generate GMP.
And so different
enzymes do this.
This enzyme here,
hypoxanthine-guanine
phosphoribosyltransferase,
which is
how you take guanine
or hypoxanthine
and make IMP or GMP
via salvage pathway
is actually a very famous
enzyme because it's
part of an inborn area
of metabolism called
Lesch-Nyhan syndrome
or hypoguanine
phosphoribosyltransferase
or HPRT.
So HPRT deficiency is what
causes Lesch-Nyhan syndrome.
And it's an inborn
error of metabolism.
You're deficient in
this HGPRT enzyme,
which means you can't salvage
guanine or hypoxanthine.
Now I bring this up, not because
we have time to talk about all
of the inborn errors
of metabolism,
but mentioning this
one really points out
that we don't
understand metabolism
as well as we think we do.
So if I ask you to
predict what would
be the consequences
of an inability
to salvage guanine
and hypoxanthine,
you might say, oh,
well, that means
that you're going to not be
able to take these things up.
Maybe you'll have excess guanine
and hypoxanthine breakdown.
And maybe you'll get more
uric acid and get gout.
And that's absolutely the case.
Patients with Lesch-Nyhan
syndrome, HPRT deficiency,
do indeed get gout.
That makes sense.
But the main problem
they have is they
have a self
mutilation phenotype.
They have a mental retardation,
a lot of neurological stuff.
And no one can
really explain why
it is that one gets this
complex neurological phenotype
because you can't salvage
guanine and hypoxanthine.
The salvage of purines,
which, again, I show here
on a slide, really that shows
all of the different enzymes
and ways here is
that HPRT to salvage
guanine and hypoxanthine
to make IMP and GMP.
There's actually
quite complex enzymes
that can allow you to
basically interconvert
all of these nucleosides
with nucleotides as well
as with the free purine bases.
Each of these enzymes has its
own syndrome associated with it
if there's humans
that are deficient.
Some of it causes
immune system problems.
There's the mental
problems I talked about
with HPRT deficiency.
Again, why certain
enzymes and pathways
are more important in
specific cells and tissues,
not so well understood.
And really, what I
want you to appreciate
is that this is
complicated and just
realize that this happens
in case you encounter it
in your first future
career and you
want to come back and study it.
OK.
All right, so we just
went through the way
that you can salvage purines
or make purines de novo.
And of course, that gives
you ribonucleotides that
can be used to generate RNA.
If you're going to
generate DNA, you then
need to, instead of generating
the ribonucleotides,
end up with the
deoxyribonucleoside
triphosphates.
And what does that mean?
So if we draw here, here's a--
for whatever base, adenine,
guanine, whatever, basically,
if we're going to generate
a deoxyribonucleoside,
we have to-- remember, this
is the 2 position of ribose.
And so we need to reduce
this 2 position of ribose--
basically, reduce
it from the alcohol
to the saturated
hydrocarbon to generate
the deoxyribonucleoside.
This is carried out
by an enzyme called
ribonucleotide reductase.
Makes sense-- we're
doing a redox reaction,
reducing that alcohol to
saturated hydrocarbon,
ribonucleotide reductase.
Interesting mechanism,
you can look it up
if you're interested.
Ribonucleotide reductase, I
drew it this way on purpose,
always acts on the dNDP, so
the nucleoside diphosphate--
sorry, on the
nucleoside diphosphate
to generate the
deoxynucleoside--
sorry, deoxynucleotide
diphosphate.
So the nucleotide diphosphate
is what ribonucleotide reductase
acts on to generate the
deoxynucleotide diphosphate.
So you would take ADP
and generate dADP, GDP,
and generate dGDP.
All right, and we'll
come back to this
in a minute for pyrimidines.
Before I get to that, I
just want to quickly go
through pyrimidine synthesis.
And so pyrimidine
synthesis is a lot simpler
than purine synthesis.
I also like to point out that
pyrimidines are also much less
abundant in cells than purines.
So remember, ATP, 10
millimolar concentration in
cells, 1 to 10 millimolar--
GTP, somewhere in the high
hundreds of micromolar.
Purines are more--
sorry, pyrimidines
are more tens of micromolar.
And so orders of magnitude, less
pyrimidines in cells than there
are purines.
And that's because
GTP, ATP, those
are important energy
transduction molecules.
We saw a couple places
where pyrimidines can be
energy transduction molecules--
UTP, glucose, et cetera.
But in general, most
reactions use ATP and GTP
as energy sources.
And so whereas
pyrimidines are primarily
for building RNA and DNA, and
so much less abundant in cells.
All right, so
pyrimidine synthesis--
get my colors.
So pyrimidine synthesis starts
with carbamoyl phosphate.
And so you'll remember
carbamoyl phosphate
from when we discussed
the urea cycle.
OK, so just as a quick
reminder, so here's bicarbonate.
I won't use colors to
start, just for time.
So if we phosphorylate
bicarbonate,
we ended up getting this
molecule, that bicarbonate.
We can then have glutamine
to glutamate conversion.
That gives us--
releases an ammonia.
That ammonia can
release that phosphate.
So ATP to ADP plus
phosphate, then gives us
this molecule, which we
can phosphorylate again
to give us this molecule,
which is carbamoyl phosphate.
Nothing new here, exactly
what we showed last time
in the urea cycle.
So carbamoyl phosphate
will react with aspartate.
So here's aspartate, the
amino acid aspartate.
OK, and that generates
this intermediate.
OK, so that generates
that intermediate.
This can now undergo
ring closure like that.
And then we end
up with a molecule
that looks like the familiar
ring structure for pyrimidine
shown here, OK?
I drew it this way
because the next step,
so this molecule is
called dihydroorotate.
And the next step is
going to be to oxidize
this carbon-carbon bond.
If we oxidize this
carbon-carbon bond,
that gives us hydride ion--
oxidizing a
carbon-carbon bond, just
like we saw in lipid
oxidation, just like we
saw in succinate dehydrogenase.
This is an FAD as an
electron acceptor.
FAD is reduced to FADH2.
This occurs as an
alternative to complex II
in the electron transport chain.
So this would occur in
the mitochondrial membrane
and be a way to
take dihydroorotate
to orotate, carried
out by an enzyme called
dihydroorotate dehydrogenase
or DHODH, which ends up
forming this alternate
electron transport chain,
electrons ultimately
ending up as oxygen.
And this generates the base
pyrimidine, the IMP equivalent,
if you will, of a
pyrimidine, which
is this molecule, which is
this molecule called orotate.
And then orotate
will react with PRPP,
generating a
pyrophosphate, which
can be cleaved to two
inorganic phosphates,
pull the reaction forward.
And we end up with
this phosphoribose.
And basically, this is going
to add to this nitrogen right
here.
And so you're used
to seeing it drawn
if I add to that
nitrogen, and now
rotate the molecule
in that direction.
And you get this molecule,
which is orotate monophosphate,
orotate monophosphate, which
is the starting pyrimidine.
And simply decarboxylating
orotate monophosphate
will give us the pyrimidine,
uridine monophosphate or UMP.
OK, and so UMP
generated in that way.
Now to turn UMP into
CTP, what happens
is UMP is phosphorylated twice.
So that's going to cost two ADP.
That's going to generate a UTP.
And then we're going
to take that UTP,
and carry out, again, the same
reaction that you saw earlier
for FGAR to FGAM, xanthine
monophosphate to guanine
monophosphate.
So I'm going to take
glutamine to glutamate,
transfer the ammonia,
take ATP to ADP plus Pi.
And basically what we're
going to end up doing
is changing that double bond
oxygen, so double bond there,
and an amino group on top.
And that is how we generate
the other major purine,
cytidine triphosphate-- or
another major pyrimidine,
cytidine triphosphate.
So UTP to CTP reaction that
we've already seen before
gets us CTP.
Now to get
deoxycytidine, obviously,
remember ribonucleotide
reductase acts on
the diphosphate, so
release of phosphates.
So now we have
cytidine diphosphate.
And now ribonucleotide
reductase can generate
deoxycytidine diphosphate.
Now remember, uracil
is not used in DNA.
Instead of uracil,
we use thymidine.
So there's no
deoxyuracil, or you
don't want to make
deoxyuracil because that
will incorporate into DNA.
That's undesirable.
And so the way you make
thymidine is you take dCDP
and you further remove
a phosphate from it.
And now you get dCMP.
And then you take the dCMP, and
you convert it back to dUMP.
Converting it back to dUMP
is basically just losing
the nitrogen. We've
seen that before when
we broke down guanine--
same reaction,
dCMP back to dUMP.
And then dUMP is a substrate
for an enzyme called thymidylate
synthase, which will
take uracil and add
a one-carbon unit there,
which is methyl group as D
and generate thymidine.
So where does that come from?
Well, we're going to
add a methyl group.
We could do that
from the folate.
Now you might guess that you'd
use 5-methyl-THF for this,
but you actually don't.
Instead, what you
use is this N5,
N10-methyl methylene THF, which
we got directly from serine
to glycine conversion.
And so this then is going to add
the methyl group to have dUMP.
So we're going to add
a methyl group there.
And this is going
to give me dTMP.
This is what thymidylate
synthase does.
But I've added a methyl group.
Remember, this is a
formaldehyde oxidation state.
So if I'm going to
add a methyl group,
that means that
one-carbon unit is getting
reduced when it's being added.
If it's being reduced, something
else has to be oxidized.
And the thing that gets
oxidized is the folate itself.
So this is-- the
tetrahydrofolate
is oxidized to instead
be a dihydrofolate,
so double bond here.
So that's oxidation.
Now it becomes dihydrofolate.
And that dihydrofolate,
of course,
has to be re-reduced back
to the tetrahydrofolate
and pick up a one-carbon unit.
And so this comes
from NADPH to NADP+.
So oxidze NADPH, reduce
dihydrofolate back
to tetrahydrofolate, pick
up another one-carbon unit
from serine to
glycine conversion.
And in the end, this is how
you synthesize thymidine.
I went through
this very quickly.
But this is actually a
very important reaction
pharmacologically.
This is an important
target for antibiotics.
So the antibiotic Bactrim,
a very famous antibiotic,
basically blocks this step
called dihydrofolate reductase,
dihydrofolate reductase, DHFR,
basically taking dihydrofolate
back to tetrahydrofolate
before it can pick up
a serine-glycine unit.
Effects on the bacteria--
very effective antibiotic.
Also, antifolate
chemotherapies-- methotrexate,
inhibitor of
dihydrofolate reductase,
one of the first
chemotherapies ever discovered,
also works because it
blocks thymidine synthesis
by preventing your ability to
recycle the dihydrofolate back
to tetrahydrofolate and carry
out thymidine synthesis.
And so ends up being
a pharmacologically,
at least for human medicine,
very important series
of reactions.
All right, so for
pyrimidine salvage,
there's almost nothing
to say about it.
You just take the pyrimidine
bases, and you add it to PRPP.
And now you have
your pyrimidine back.
And so nothing
more to say there.
And really, what I want to do
is close with a few comments
about regulation of nucleoside
and nucleotide metabolism.
And so obviously,
if you're going
to synthesize RNA
and DNA, you need
to have the right
ratios of nucleotides.
So if your RNA polymerase
is making an RNA molecule
and it doesn't have the right
base, it can't keep going.
And this is particularly
a problem for synthesis
because remember, and as you
will learn or have learned
in cell biology,
you have to license
your origins of
replication before you
start DNA replication.
And that prevents you
from ever replicating
the same amount of DNA
twice, meaning you say,
here's where you start.
And once you start, you
can't stop until you
finish DNA replication.
Well, this becomes
a tremendous problem
if you're trying to
replicate your DNA and you
run out of nucleosides
or nucleotides.
And so there has to be
complex mechanisms in place
to make sure that
cells always have
the right levels of
nucleotide triphosphates
and deoxynucleotide
triphosphates.
And so there's complex
feedbacks that we
could give a whole lecture on.
But for the purposes
of today, I just
want you to be familiar
and know that they're here.
And they also all make sense.
They fit exactly with what we've
talked about in other pathways.
And so shown here on
the slide is the control
of purine synthesis.
And so this makes perfect sense.
So if you have
plenty of purines,
meaning you have a
lot of AMP, GMP, IMP.
Well, what do you do?
Well, don't charge the
ribose 5-phosphate to PRPP.
Or don't carry out the first
step in purine synthesis
where you take that
ammonia from glutamine
and take PRPP and add it to the
PRPP to begin purine synthesis.
And so all of these
purine monophosphates
inhibit this early steps of
purine synthesis, makes sense.
What if you have an imbalance
in your AMP and GMP pools?
Well, the way you
prevent that, remember,
we already discussed that
to turn IMP into AMP,
you use GTP as an
energy phosphate donor.
And to turn IMP into GMP, you
use ATP as an energy phosphate
donor.
So that's one way
you regulate this.
But the other thing is if
you have enough AMP, well,
don't try to make AMP.
And if you have enough
GMP, don't try to make GMP.
And so there's
feedbacks there as well
that add to balancing
the AMP and GMP pools.
What about pyrimidines?
Well, pyrimidines-- simpler
synthesis, simpler regulation.
If you have enough
pyrimidines, enough CTP,
don't do the first
step where you
take aspartate and
carbamoyl phosphate
and generate that first step
here in pyrimidine synthesis.
dNTPs, obviously, as I said,
is particularly critical
because once you start
replicating your DNA,
you always have to
have the right balance
of deoxyribonucleotides.
And so ribonucleotide
reductase, that
enzyme up there that basically
balances and synthesizes
your deoxyribonucleotides, it
has incredibly complex feedback
mechanisms that one could spend
a whole lecture talking about.
But effectively, it has
various feedback mechanisms
with allosteric sites and
other feedbacks that are still,
honestly, being worked
out, that, in the end,
is a way that helps
you balance to make
sure you have the
right levels of all
the different
deoxyribonucleotides
in the end.
All right, if you're interested
more in the feedbacks
of ribonucleotide
reductase, these
are covered well
in your textbook.
Any of the topics that
we didn't have time
to cover that might become
relevant for your future
endeavors in biology,
medicine, metabolism, whatever,
all of those are well covered.
And hopefully, if you could
absorb some of the concepts
that I tried to impart to you
about how metabolism works,
you can understand
those pathways better.
Hope you enjoyed 7.05.
Hope you enjoyed learning
about metabolism.
And thank you very much
for your attention.